history is often filled with things that
aren't very fun a notable amongst those
is disease sometimes it will end the
reign of an important monarch sometimes
it will stop a war in its tracks but
every few centuries there's a major
outbreak a pandemic and one of the most
notable of these was the influenza
outbreak of 1918 better known as the
Spanish flu so how did this pandemic
play out well first of all it's
important to note that there's no
definitive answer on where this outbreak
actually came from some say it started
in a British Army field hospital in
France because all those sick people
next to each other was a breeding ground
for disease some argue that it
originated in southern China because the
government there had reported a deadly
flu there in 1917 and there are others
that say it started in Kansas and
American soldiers brought it with them
to the Western Front what we know for
sure is that it definitely didn't start
in Spain so why is it called the Spanish
flu then well the reason is that during
the first world war if the on tonton
central power was implemented strict
censorship at the press and this
included suppressing the flu outbreak
because authorities were concerned it
would demoralize troops Spain however
was a neutral country and so had no
censorship and its papers were free to
discuss the outbreak of flu which had
spread there from France also given that
the king of Spain himself got very sick
many people only knew about the deadly
flu there and had no idea that it was
spreading in their own countries hence
the name
so to summarize the outbreak the Spanish
influenza pandemic infected one in three
people globally and of those it killed
roughly 10% most deaths came from the
flu causing pneumonia fortunately though
pneumonia could easily be treated by
antibiotics
unfortunately antibiotics hadn't been
invented yet and so you simply had to
hope for the best
in the end the pandemic reached all
corners of the world and killed about 40
to 50 million people globally in the
space of a year and to put this into
perspective World War one could about
twelve million people over the course of
four years so the Spanish flu came in
three waves and the first one hit in
March to April of 1918 but this was the
least deadly of all waves by May or June
though the flu had largely disappeared
until it popped back up in France in
late October and it was this second wave
which was the big one to put it into
perspective in six weeks the illness
killed 400,000 people in the United
States and 200,000 in Germany and its
victims were mostly young adults places
like India with the hardest hit though
with the death toll there alone being
over 10 million people in two months
and the third wave occurred around the
beginning of 1919 and whilst also deadly
wasn't as bad as the previous over the
course of two months he killed 70,000
people in Britain and slightly more in
Germany after this though the flu just
simply well disappeared leaving the
world to pick up the pieces and return
to a sense of normalcy so how did
nations try to stop it well we'll look
at Italy's attempt for the answer the
first outbreak barely affected the
nation and soldiers on the front were
only made mildly and well but it was the
second wave which began in cesano in
September of 1918 that was the
devastating one when soldiers on the
front started to die in droves the
government knew that strict measures had
to be taken the problem was that Italy
wasn't a hugely developed nation at this
point and so food was severely limited
by the war effort to medical staff and
equipment were prioritized for the army
in the end as millions of people became
unwell combat medics were sent back and
first year medical students were given
control of entire hospitals travel
between cities was limited but
ultimately this wasn't enough to stop
its spread the Italian government
implemented numerous strategies one
advice was given to people to wash their
hands often to isolate the sick and to
produce contact with their neighbors
which was difficult given that people
had to kefir rations daily the
government conscripted prisoners of war
to clean the streets gave police
officers face masks and reserved
hospitals for only the very sick it
banned public gatherings closed schools
and bought hospital visitors and it was
this aspect no church no seeing sick
relatives are no attending their
funerals which caused a deep trauma in
Italian society reminiscent of the Black
Death six centuries earlier like
everywhere else the last wave went as
quick as the first one came in in Italy
the flu killed 600,000 people in six
months something many people wonder is
that given how destructive the Spanish
flu was why isn't it better remembered
and for that there are two reasons the
first was that it occurred towards the
end of the first world war and so that
event takes precedence the second was
that during this period pandemics were
fairly common and people were used to
cholera typhoid plague and other
diseases ravaging their communities and
combined with people being numb to so
many young deaths in the war much of the
world had become well pretty used to it
which is why the Spanish flu was always
seen as a footnote to the first world
war because too many people at the time
it was I hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching with the
special thanks to my patrons James
Bissonnette John lucid a man of culture
danny Maloney little Holliday John bass
guest Robert
house moe James Castaneda Aaron the
white Jordan Longley Gustav Swann
Marcus ours nur Rashid Ali spinning
three plates filled oink oink David
Silverman
Maggie packs Kowski Spencer Lightfoot
Lexy Schwinn Kelly moneymaker
Anthony Beckett Robert Wetzel sky
Chappell Marvin Castle
Winston Heyward and Izzy